le travail ils ont j'aime à maupiti
encore en pagne deux sacs de réparation
la semaine dernière elle est encore en
pagne le pain qui va se prendre dans la
tête le garagiste ça va faire très très
mal
c'est pas vrai ça 2 sag a dit non enfin
heureusement côté coeur là cette fois je
crois que j'ai carrément trouver le
bonheur
ah oui j'ai rencontré une nana didon
allait super hyper extra c'est un mec
non quand je dis c'est un mec c'est une
façon de parler ou sais que tu vas
méfie-toi sabari tout à l'heure et
saraya pauvre mec attend que je te
raconte l'histoire tu essaies on était
aux voltigeurs la bois à gambetta
on était en train de se faire une petite
mousse tranquille peinard molopo cheap
et où tu as juste avant l'arrivée des
agents
et d'un seul coup il ya 7 j/7 qui en dit
long on aurait vu la classe de la nana
blonde et ou veste de cuir futal de cuir
avec les clous les aigles et tout le
bordel toi ta nana qui jette quand même
tout de suite et que c'est quand même
assez rare et alors tu sais toujours ce
qui se passe là bas surtout à gambetta
ksila c'est leur père quand même à
chaque fois qu'il est une anna qui se
ramènent s'est tout de suite les
conneries comment vas-tu de poils
l'étoile la matelas comme tu voitures à
bras tuer n'importe quoi c'est vrai les
nanas sa pelouse foot c'est normal 1
alors elle au lieu de ça ils ont tu sais
pas ce qui est fait elle attrape une
chaise comme ça et à fait eu il ya
quelqu'un qui est pas content là dedans
il ya un mec dans le fond au lieu de
s'écraser monopole chiper tout way de
roupiller tranquillo spénard dans son
coin le tard et il lève le doigt dit au
lieu de travail à coup de genou dans le
vide le pif écrasé deux yeux au beurre
noir
le mec qui s'est retrouvé par terre les
moustaches en croatie le camp où il a
failli souffler son gaz via leur a été
tellement énervée claquement sec fri des
grands coups de pompes au maire ma pompe
qui encore déchirée dans un sac de
réparation la semaine dernière elle est
encore déchiré le pain qui va se prendre
dans la tête le marchand de chaussures
safer ferait très mal à ses parents
étaient voir le garagiste et le marchand
de conflits mois de jumeaux la semaine
bref je reviens à mon histoire c'est
cette anam avait vachement intéressé
mois
bon c'est vrai c'est normal parce que tu
vois quand même plus souvent des mecs
qui castagne des maîtres que moins fort
que que des nanas qui chie corps des
mecs c'est vrai c'est plus rare dans
l'ensemble 1 alors moi je me suis dit
celle-là il n'y a pas de problème il
faut que j cause plus sa tombe est
vachement bien parce que j'étais super
bien ça paie enfin moi je trouve
j'avais les ray ban j'avais la chemise à
quoi la bague avec la tête de mort la
matraque soupe la chaîne de vélo tout le
bordel toi
alors je me suis ramené à côté d'elle
comme ça et je les regardais eu presque
dans les yeux toi
j'y fais comment ça va baby là tu me
crois où tu me crois pas là la nama fil
d'une tard j'ai fait quatre tours et
demi je me suis retrouvé par terre c'est
tout juste si j'étais pas sorti de mes
baskets non mais tu vois un peu la gêne
devant les copains au le travail chez et
puis quoi faire tourner
il fallait bien que je me relève parce
que tu comprends la sueur ça dure qu'un
temps
1 alors je me suis relevé doucement je
les regardais comme ça vachement western
et j'y fais on sort me fais ok ayant les
sorties et c'est quand on est arrivés
sur le trottoir toi moi j'avais eu le
temps de réfléchir je me suis dit quand
même qu'on est un maître une nana il ya
d'autres moyens de se fendre la gueule
que ce chicorée c'est vrai alors j'ai
dit on va faire un tour à me fais ok
alors on a sauté sur mon arlit 1
maintenant c'est pas vraiment une harley
c'est à dire c'est une mob ordinaire que
j'ai rajouté un guidon style harley mais
pour la france est suffisant tu peut
frimer avec ça alors on a roulé roulé
roulé roulé roulé on s'est retrouvé au
moins que je croie porte maillot toi tu
es là on s'est arrêté et on a causé est
très très très très vite on a compris
que on étaient faits l'un pour l'autre
surtout moi d'ailleurs moi j'ai dit je
trouve ça vachement chouette el ahmadi
qui a trouvé ça chouette aussi bref on
l'était déjà 2 à trouver ça chouette
hein et puis on s'est aperçu très vite
qu'on avait les mêmes idées sur la vie
et que c'est quand même vachement
important quand on est un couple d'avoir
les mêmes idées sur la vie question
entendre du coupé tous sains et le coup
classique qui se passe toujours quand et
avec une disquette que tu as les mêmes
idées qu'elle sur la vie toi tu as envie
de rouler une pelle et crac bonjour
madame on sait rouler une pelle porte
maillot
et depuis c'est carrément le zew bonheur
un nom là les problèmes parce que nous
et aia
non c'est pas qu'il ya des problèmes bon
s'il ya c'est que tu te rends compte
d'une anaky chic or les mecs c'est pas
toujours il n'a la facilité aux grands
elle est très très chef comme d'un
attrait très autoritaire selon moi j'ai
dit méfie-toi méfie toi je me laisserais
pas monté sur les avions non mais sans
blague
qu'est ce que croient qu'on peut pas se
passer d'elle non mais peut être très
bien le procès d'els -10 2 perdu une de
retrouvée non mais peut dire ça comme
l'autre fois laquelle a pas voulu venir
au cinéma avec moi là un mois je suis
allé tout seul et puis ça a rien changé
parce que le film il était aussi bien